[Music]
all right so I am here with Markus and
McFeely two titans of comic book legend
Titans as a loaded word oh it's
intentionally a loaded word and and
legend as well there's a lot in there I
appreciate the fact that you guys are so
invested in the world that everyone at
this convention grew up with and it
feels like it's coming from a place of
heart and there's just so much detail
and everything you guys write I was at
the Agbo announcement earlier today and
I feel like we got another nine movie
slate that none of us were ready for
which things are you guys involved with
I know you're part of that process yes
no we're partners in egg Bo so we've
written one script we were run script
last year which is sort of a true-life
important political story and then this
year we're working on electric state
that's the sort of post-apocalyptic
alternate 1996 girl in a robot movie
yeah we've been we're producing Thomas
Crown Affair so that means we helped
Matt Carnahan sort of shape the story
and I don't know if anything else on
that lists were things that were you're
touching at the moment yeah yeah working
on a bunch of other stuff I mean
slightly secret it is it is a bit of a
you know we are we are lighting a bunch
of fires that's right
can you say a number like is there yes
Chris and I we sort of are helping
Shepherd helping other writers Shepherd
maybe five or six problem tentpole type
movies and then we're electric state is
meant to be one that we write and then
we'll probably will write another will
write one every year and then help out
where we can and you know sort of sit in
the room and hombre idle hands not
having a little more idle it'd be a
better for my brain now endgame is
coming out on digital on July 30th and
then blu-ray on August 13th I'm a
tangible media guy the clouds there's
some magic and the smell of opening the
disc the first time I will not let go
now I'm wondering with this ending this
giant 11-year run I love the fact that
Tony and caps arcs exchange we've got
selfish to selfless and vice versa
and then for basically finding himself
we've got the Holy Trinity all having
self existential crises
Oh early did those seeds get planted as
for your perspective on where you wanted
it to end if it worked out well I think
you could see particularly by the time
of civil war that Toni and Steve were
starting to cross over where Steve was
you know Steve was rebelling against
against making fertilization and Tony
was signing up with the government and
and it was a very you know it was not
initially started intentional right but
when we saw it happening it it was it
felt oh that's that's really meaty yeah
we don't take it we had a point probably
late 2015 as we were outlining what we
realized we knew where we kind of wanted
to take Tony and Steve by the end and it
was sort of a in the day moment where we
went oh in order to become his best self
tony stark's gonna have to lose his life
in order to become his best self Steve
Rogers is gonna have to get one right
now movies but yeah but that seemed a
good flag to drive into the ground in
the center of the X was fittingly Civil
War in a way yeah yeah okay now is there
any I know the rewrite process is insane
and I know spider-man there was a script
without and with and there's our Civil
War for some war for sure now were there
any darlings you had the kill that are
especially hard now that it's kind of
you know a different chapter starting it
was there a moment that you really were
like man I wanted that in Civil War in
we started I'm sure there are I mean
part of the way we write and part of the
Marvel process is you know if you have
darlings yet you're not gonna that
you're gonna gum up the works okay you
know you have to be willing to to demo
them out and then and and then tear them
down if no matter how satisfying they
are and the 95% of the time the reason
they leave is because they're not on
story and it's impossible to defend it
right those movies are long they're
thick there's a lot going on yeah if
it's not on the stand infinity war if
it's not on the stone plot it went you
know it just goodbye we had all sorts of
sort of before--the fan out before Hulk
smashes through the window all sorts of
here's what we're doing now catch up on
on all the people universally there was
a great I liked it I didn't but is
pretty familiar but terrorists in the
Middle East have have taken a bunch of
hostages and they have bags over their
heads and they bring him in and they're
gonna and they start taking the bags off
right and they they're starting being
mean to these people and the last bag
they take off and it's Steve Rogers oh
yeah but in a way in a way that's Rd
that leads to the satisfaction of Steve
appearing behind the train that's right
as we realize the other there's a lot of
pleasure to suddenly realizing you have
Captain America yes somebody's ass and
and I think that vibe fed fed that train
moment so none of these are wasted you
just have to let them go and they're and
they're great little you guys have
little to built-in Alton universe so
you've got another option where
headcanon can be alternate is there a
different writing process for writing
like a gourmet coffee like the Marvel
Universe versus like monster energy like
pain and gain because I love both I mean
certainly pain and gain is more
satirical sure and the process like you
know when you work for Marvel you're
sort of a full-time job sitting around a
table with a lot of people trying to
figure it out
go back grind a lot of grinding right
and that that was a script that we wrote
we did like two drafts and then turned
it over and and then Michael did what he
did with it so it's it's not like we
were in Miami on set every day okay and
in marble we are but with all of them
you know in paint again you're dealing
with just reprehensible Psychopaths but
you still have to find the humanity in
them and you still have to find some
chip of likability in them or the movie
is just going to turn into porn and it's
the same thing with superheroes if you
don't find the P
inside the suits it's just noise so in
some ways all the movies we write at the
same you know it's just gonna be a lot
of clatter unless you get to the person
inside and can lock into that like a
horror movie without the heart it's just
gore like it's a local character the
sign I've seen plenty of those yeah
that's the problem with now if there was
an alternate universe movie that was not
tied at all to anything like marvel apes
or 2099 or some what is there any other
universe you'd love to play in if you
there were no ties no no no Marvel
Universe yeah 16:02 I mean the one with
the medieval one is fun there are things
I wouldn't do I like you know I wouldn't
do the Ultimates that's also the thing
we as as the MCU is its own iteration
right we're free to sample from
everybody's platter and so you know I
certainly haven't felt held back liya
that is not the place that where they
will tell you are you kidding I can't do
that it's like do it as fans if there
was an alternate timeline where he had
infinite budget and then the studio did
they how does this even exist in front
of me is there any characters you'd love
to just take and run with I bring up a
couple of a couple of characters every
time one moon night cuz I find him
fascinating sure because he's the
schizophrenic he's Jewish she's he's
cool hey you know you'd have to do a lot
of work but that's what jobs are and I
sincerely think MODOK could be
terrifying Oh like a big scary head if
you saw that coming down the hallway you
would
just crap your pants like it would be
great any for you you know I'm a bit of
an Anglophile I just like a you know
sort of part of me wants to drop my life
and move to London so if you told me we
could do is sort of a Union Jack or
Captain Britain sort of you know a bond
you know a skewed thing yeah yeah I
would kind of dig that a mild far from
home spoiler the fact that we had the
universe named in the far from home
trailer that didn't land of Captain
Britain was so painful the fact that I
thought Jake Gyllenhaal's from is there
a moment a deep cut that most people
don't catch that is still in your movies
that you've written to frame a comic
never see that just people don't know
about like I love the the most obvious
one on the posters is the Civil War nod
that's so clearly there is there
anything that's a deep cut that we
haven't noticed this is the the candy
store of Marvel is that yeah what used
to be deep cuts are now a site guideline
applaud threats like when we made cap
one and Sebastian got cast we were like
boy he secretly would make a great
winter soul there's nothing about the
Winter Soldier in that movie yeah like
that was a deep gun you know now it's
integral so it's hard to think of
something that hasn't been picked up and
fleshed out at this point right oh I
don't even know yeah I don't like Arnim
Zola was a deep cut until we have a full
on when you introduce him he's already
on a screen yeah I'm out and I love it
we get the Marvel Universe is loved
enough that people I've already picked
over its bones and yeah that's the
bat-rope to leave her leaps in another
frame like I can't escape George save
the airplane and he's pretty I think
that's the goal we've often tried to
resurrect or make better things that
could be silly ya know what's the word
I'm looking for
rehabilitate yeah so that like big
paste-pot pete movie coming oh it's
coming I'm excited spider-man 3 pays
puppy it's coming
there one character as fans that you're
most excited to see with this Fox Marvel
murderer not necessarily like it to play
with but like who are you ready to see
with us I mean a good surfer movie would
be great yeah that would be if you take
it full on yeah
cosmic I want Keanu just for like I like
the voice in the 80s we always say that
whenever we cast it we always cast the
guy you just saw right and Marvel didn't
do that
no no that's fake oh they go find that
guy so Silver Surfer that would that
would be my first blush cuz uh you know
I think x-men should rest a second same
it could be wrong but I think you should
rest and then but surfer could use a
really good stand alone you know now uh
Perry does this thing one of the other
hosts in the channel she does this would
you rather but I wanted to comic eyes it
so okay this is a hard game would you
rather if you had to kill a storyline so
it never existed we're removing can and
removing continuity okay would you
rather kill demon in a bottle or doom
quest which was Duke listen to me quest
is the one where God doom basically
builds an Iron Man type suit and then it
builds to that so I'm assuming you'd
want to kill it because even the models
great quest gone okay cap no more or
death of cat yeah your stuff the titles
before is like leads to Nomad and death
of cap is when you get shot in the
stomach on the step what do you kept no
more yeah you got I mean I keep kept The
Ballad of beta ray bill or God butcher
which ones God butchers the new Jason
Aaron number one that started his
channel
oh there you go God butchers gone
Craven's last hunt or kid who collects
spider-man
yeah the make-a-wish issue the the
beautiful you know I'm also we've been
writing these Craven is a strange
character I don't know do you
alright all right so Craven I think so
Craven makes the cut children George
Perez is web of intrigue where he took
over Black Widow and had that great
reintroduction Black Widow or mark
Wade's shields most-wanted verse she was
being hunted by shield
these are things that don't even know
okay this is the thing I've read I've
read almost all of them but I don't know
the titles of the trade paperback to
ringing in my mind the same thing with
Starlin like we read all of starland
yeah I don't quite know the difference
between gauntlet and war you know in
resurrection and but I would say the one
where she I would keep the one where
she's not being hunted by shield look
how many people get hunted by shield
that's fishy one of the last ones last
three mat fractions life is a weapon or
Brian Michael Bendis is Dark Reign for
hockey life is a weapon as the as
fraction still one the arts by yes love
that yeah keep them okay beautiful and
then World War Hulk or mr. Fixit don't
fix it
and finally Wolverine now that he's
becoming part cannon enemy of the state
where he's being hunted or old man Logan
keep old man Logan although it it's its
own timeline it's grown so much and now
there's a whole game there's an old man
Hawkeye and a lock well it's gotten
crazy nine months into old man quill
things have gotten crazy is there
anything you guys are reading if there
was a gateway drug for comics you'd
recommend people that haven't gotten in
the world I didn't grow up a comic guy
okay so my comic knowledge is only based
on research for this job and for this
well lifestyle for the last I was a Star
Wars guy I was a mild Dungeons & Dragons
guy so I've fallen in love with these
characters as of now I so you know I can
get called out for not being a comic
book fan but I I think it's allowed both
of us because Chris was a x-men guy
early on but less so as he got older you
know we're coming at it was slightly
fresh your eyes we're trying to make big
blockbuster stories out of this stuff
it's not merely you know Easter Egg City
you know it's what's the journey of
these humans and if there's time we'll
put in this and this but in general we
put those things in to support the story
we're telling not just as wallpaper that
said there was a my cousin gave me a big
box of comics when I was a kid and they
all had like no covers
was a mess but I read through the damn
thing a million times there's an issue
of the Avengers that was in the back of
my mind and Len later in the front of my
mind when we were working on this I
think called death be not proud where
it's probably 60s where it's the
Avengers it's an iteration of the
Avengers where Panther is in it at some
point okay
they have I think captured an old Doctor
Doom base or something like that and
there's a time machine in it okay and oh
is this they go back to when Zemo is
launching the rocket and and cap has to
witness he and Bucky getting on that
thing and Bucky gonna his Bucky's gonna
die again yeah
and wasp is at the controls back in the
present day and falls asleep and hits
the switch that materializes them in the
past and suddenly they have the
opportunity to actually stop from being
killed there's a big fight and then she
manages to press the button and keep
bringing them back again he's talking
about now I've been had just as I
expected to be thank you so much and I
never thought we could top the moment
that the lightning God appeared in the
Infinity war but then Mjolnir wielding
cap changed my life so thank you guys so
much for all you've done for this magic
world please tell these men what they
mean to you thank you so much guys
appreciate it Cheers thanks everybody